Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Como mucho de nosotros, cuando era chico,
quería tener superpoderes.
Anticipando lo que después
leería en tantos libros
y vería en tantas películas,
soñaba con curar y con tener
poderes mágicos para construir cosas.
Soñaba con defender
pequeñas aldeas de terribles invasores.
Después el tiempo
nos da un baño de realidad.
Perdés el subte y no tenés
la varita mágica de Harry Potter.
Ves imperios invadir pequeñas aldeas
y no tenés la poción de Panoramix
para defenderlos.
Pero algo de esa vocación de chico
quedó en mí
y, casi sin darme cuenta,
toda la vida me dediqué a mirar
y a tratar de entender
cómo funcionan esos superpoderes,
no ya en mi imaginación,
sino en el mundo real.
Hoy quiero compartir con Uds. seis ideas
para desarrollar uno de
los principales superpoderes.
Tal vez, el más importante
en esta situación que toca vivir,
que es el superpoder de pensar mejor.
Obviamente, hay muchos más superpoderes
y muchas más herramientas
para pensar mejor.
Pero hoy me quiero enfocar en las
que creo que son menos conocidas.
Las que les voy a contar
no son ideas mías.
Las aprendí de otros.
Y esta es, tal vez,
la principal de todas las ideas.
Algo así como la "idea cero"
de esto que les voy a contar.
Que somos capaces de aprender.
Y que nuestra capacidad de pensar
no viene dada ni está fija
sino que puede ser desarrollada,
poblando nuestra mente
con ideas potentes y practicando.
Entonces ahí vamos, les cuento
seis ideas que aprendí de otros
para pensar mejor.
La primera: imagínense
que entran en un gimnasio.
Miran, pesas en el piso,
aparatos vacíos, bicicletas fijas.
Se dan media vuelta, se van al bar,
piden un café con leche con tres
medialunas de manteca y se las comen.
No funciona así, ¿no?
Nuestro cuerpo no mejora con esto.
Bueno, con pensar pasa lo mismo.
No cuenta "poder" pensar.
Lo que cuenta es pensar.
Tenemos que practicar pensar.
Desarrollar en nosotros
el hábito de pensar.
Y darnos el tiempo para pensar.
La inteligencia no es algo
que se tiene o no se tiene.
Es algo que se usa o no se usa.
La segunda; dice el dicho:
"Quien solo tiene un martillo
ve todos los problemas como un clavo".
Pero si tenemos que sacar un tornillo
no nos sirve un martillo,
ni hacer de cuenta que es un clavo.
Si tenemos un tornillo
necesitamos un destornillador.
Y si necesitamos cortar algo
necesitamos un serrucho.
Tener una caja de herramientas
con más herramientas
nos permite hacer más cosas,
solucionar más problemas.
Y las herramientas de la mente
se llaman modelos mentales.
Si solo tenemos un modelo mental
vamos a pensar todos los problemas
con ese modelo,
como si tratáramos de sacar
un tornillo con un serrucho.
Si tenemos muchos modelos mentales
nuestra mente es mucho más potente.
Pero ¿a dónde se encuentran
esos modelos mentales?
¿De dónde los sacamos?
Bueno, se encuentran
en distintas disciplinas,
en distintos lugares
y en distintos tiempos.
Por ejemplo,
hay modelos mentales interesantes
en la física, en la biología,
en la ingeniería, en la psicología.
Y también hay modelos mentales distintos
en Japón, en Tanzania y en Argentina.
Hay modelos mentales en el antiguo Egipto,
3000 años antes de Cristo,
en la Edad Media y en nuestro tiempo.
Para pensar mejor tenemos que ampliar
la caja de herramientas
de nuestra cabeza.
Si no, todos los problemas
nos van a parecer un clavo.
La tercera: Hace poco estaba en el club
y en la mesa de al lado un hombre
le decía a sus amigos
que le había dicho de todo
al profesor de fútbol de su hijo,
adelante de su hijo y de sus compañeros,
por un error que el profesor
había cometido.
El hombre tenía razón en todo
lo que le decía a sus amigos,
y lo que le había dicho al profesor.
Pero no se daba cuenta
de que, al decirle esto,
estaba generando un mal
mucho mayor en su hijo.
Estaba dejándolo como un tonto
adelante de sus amigos
y estaba deslegitimando al profesor
adelante de todos los chicos
que tenían que aprender de él.
Muchas veces no nos damos cuenta
de que estar enfocados
en ganar en una escala
nos hace tener éxito en esa escala
y, sin saberlo, hacemos cosas
que nos hacen perder
en otra escala más importante.
Ganar una discusión y perder
una amistad, por ejemplo.
Ganar plata y perder libertad.
O ganar libertad y perder amor.
Cuando actuamos pensemos en qué escalas
impacta lo que vamos a hacer
y cuál es la escala más importante
en la que tenemos que pensar cómo actuar.
La cuarta: "El principito" nos enseñó
que lo esencial es invisible a los ojos.
Es a través de los ojos, de los sentidos,
donde generamos nuestras impresiones.
Y las impresiones nos generan emociones.
Y las emociones nos hacen actuar.
Por ejemplo ahora, en la pandemia.
Nos llegaban muchos datos
de la situación de China.
Pero esos datos no generaban impresiones,
no generaban emociones,
y no hacían que actuemos.
Cuando empezaron a llegar
imágenes de Italia,
un país que sentimos más familiar
y parecido que China,
esas impresiones sí generaron emoción:
el miedo.
Y el miedo generó acción:
Que estemos ahora todos
guardados preventivamente,
lo que está muy bien.
Esta vez tuvimos la suerte
de que el miedo nos dio tiempo
porque le pasó a alguien parecido
antes que a nosotros.
Pero muchas veces es importante actuar
cuando todavía no vemos ni sentimos.
La práctica de anticipar
es lo que nos distingue
a la civilización moderna
de la prehistórica.
Cazar es una cosa.
Tenés hambre, cazás,
tenés una recompensa inmediata:
te comés lo que cazaste.
Pero cultivar es muy distinto:
Hacés el esfuerzo ahora
para algo que vas a aprovechar
dentro de seis meses o un año.
Este es el pilar de casi todo
lo que tenemos.
Prevenir no genera aplausos,
porque estás evitando algo
que nadie ve ni siente,
pero salva vidas.
Desarrollar nuestra capacidad
de actuar antes de sentir,
es decir, desarrollar
nuestra capacidad de anticipar,
es una de las principales
habilidades de pensar bien.
Pensemos un minuto.
¿Qué tenemos que anticipar ahora
que todavía no sentimos ni vemos?
La quinta: Todos evaluamos las cosas
de acuerdo a nuestras expectativas.
Si algo malo dura tres meses y pensamos
que iba a durar seis meses
estamos contentos.
Si algo malo dura tres meses y pensamos
que iba a durar un mes
estamos tristes.
Es el mismo tiempo, son tres meses.
Pero lo vivimos completamente distinto.
Si nos programamos
para correr 10 km, por ejemplo,
al kilómetro 9 estamos exhaustos.
Si nos programamos para correr 20 km,
al kilómetro 9 estamos impecables.
Hacemos un culto de la resiliencia.
Pero la clave de la resiliencia
es manejar bien las expectativas.
La sexta y última:
¿Alguna vez les pasó que se encontraron
con un conocido en un lugar rarísimo?
Estás caminando por un pueblito
en el medio de la nada y ¡pum!
un compañero de la secundaria
que no veías hacía 15 años.
No podés creer la casualidad,
lo improbable que es
encontrarlo en ese lugar.
Es verdad, encontrar
a ese compañero en ese lugar
es algo totalmente improbable.
Pero, como conocemos tanta gente,
es muy probable encontrar a alguien
en un lugar muy improbable.
De hecho, nos pasa todo el tiempo.
Bueno, con el resto de la vida es igual.
Hay tantas cosas improbables
que es muy probable
que nos pase algo muy improbable.
El problema es que nuestra mente
nos hace pensar
que lo improbable es imposible.
Y no lo es.
Dice el dicho que los pronósticos
dicen mucho del pronosticador
y poco del futuro.
No sabemos lo que va a pasar.
Ni ahora, ni tampoco
en tiempos más normales.
Tenemos que aprender a convivir
con la incertidumbre.
Y, a lo mejor, la forma inteligente
de convivir con la incertidumbre,
es dejar siempre muchas puertas abiertas.
No pensar solo en lo más probable
y buscar maneras de cuidarnos
de cosas graves, cuando sea posible,
aunque sean muy improbables.
Y si alguien alguna vez te pregunta
por qué tenés siempre el auto
con el tanque de nafta lleno,
contestale que porque
una vez te encontraste
en un pueblito del otro lado del mundo
con un compañero de la secundaria
que no veías hace 15 años.
Les decía al principio que
la idea cero de esta charla,
seguramente la más importante,
es desarrollar
nuestra capacidad de aprender.
Y aprender tiene que ver
con estar al acecho.
Al acecho de ideas que
nos hagan cambiar de forma de pensar,
y de personas con las que
cultivar esas ideas.
Rodearnos de personas que enriquezcan
nuestra forma de pensar.
No se trata de convencer a otros.
Se trata de cambiar
nuestras propias ideas.
En una entrevista a Borges hace 40 años
el entrevistador le hizo una pregunta.
Y cuando Borges le contestó,
el entrevistador le dijo
"Eso mismo Ud. me contestó
a esa misma pregunta hace cuatro años".
Borges se quedó callado,
lo miró y le dijo:
"Le pido disculpas, no he tenido
mucho tiempo de pensar en ese tema
durante estos cuatro años".
Aprovechemos este momento límite
que nos toca vivir
para estar al acecho de nuevas ideas,
de las nuevas ideas que están surgiendo
y estar siempre abiertos a cambiar
nuestra forma de pensar.
Gracias.